oh that is boiled that is not going into
my body this morning
[Music]
[Applause]
hi I'm Frankie corio
and what's your name hello my name is
Paul meskill and this is snack Wars for
a lab Bible so we are doing a UK versus
Ireland today why are we doing that
because he's Irish and I'm Scottish yeah
I am closing my eyes
there we go yeah wow oh Marmite that's
not a good start potato great start okay
so have you give your dry title before
are they just crisps no they're not just
crisps
yeah okay so if you want a mermaid on it
both I will not want mama I think you'll
like this okay okay it's also half nine
and we're eating crisp sandwiches so
that's a good start to anything okay
what are you doing are you checking no
it's a crisp you've never had a crisp
sandwich that's all thanks though okay
so you can have okay all right bro all
right bro I feel like I'm gonna put it
all done me I'm definitely gonna pour it
off just eat it over the place
yeah yeah all right ready
okay
it's nice right do you want to make me a
Marmite sandwich I've actually honestly
never had Marmite
no don't don't go heavy on it please
there we go yes please there you go
so Frank have you ever had Marmite
before I don't think so okay I've heard
of my writing saying that you're not
supposed to put a lot on yeah
gross
oh yes Paul you you that's actually
making my mouth water in like the bad
way how can you write for it in a bad
way did you know like when you're back
in no just leave it out leave it leave
it that's like gross right
so what is oh yeah
I'm gonna take a tiny bit of this no I
think you should eat it all that's not
gonna happen
from the upgrade how does it taste what
does it taste like kind of salty you
have to try it you haven't tried it just
do a tiny bit of it or something no
there's no Marmite yeah
we used it it looks horrible it looks
Orange
there you go it's not the worst yeah
yeah I think the winner is tato's yeah
hold on
okay
I hope these are more sweet
oh for God
so we've got oh my God I'm not really
excited we've got premium I guess it's
um
Irish stew yeah um what do you think
this tastes like for is it good it's
going to be nicer than this this looks
like dog food how this is nice what's in
I guess is it like well I'm heart
okay what's inside of it okay
what are lamb lobes maybe it's ear loops
let's do a little bowl of each of these
yeah a ball no like a small portion
that is
not nice
all right we'll pour it stew is actually
nice but it doesn't look like I'm not
gonna yeah it doesn't look very nice
does it watch this this is gonna be
it looks like Savory porridge like okay
all right all right it's nice
very salty okay
can I make a spoon for you so you get a
nice I'm gonna see what I see here I see
carrots mutton what is that uh like
older sheep
all right try that okay
just yeah
yeah it's nice right not as bad as the
mermaid okay I need to try this yeah
yeah I will be eating your haggis thanks
I think
The Haggis surprised me pleasantly so
I'm gonna I feel like if it was nicer
haggis and not in a can like if you've
maybe extended the budget a little bit
further and spent more money on this I
would go for the Haggis so I'm gonna go
haggis Frankie you agree yeah great I
guess
right I can't tell what this is
Irish very popular we haven't had a lot
in my life so this could be this I'm
worried about I don't know what this is
Gentleman's Relish oh okay that fish
it has a picture of a fish on it
delicious on hot toast cold
this is gonna be pretty rough this is
salted anchovies
I'm really leaning on really just I
don't need to taste that in my life I
don't think
let's open it and see what the if it was
something like Nutella in there then I
would definitely eat it like a little
travel size portion of Nutella yeah you
can just stick in your pocket right but
instead they go okay good
to appreciate the fine flavor of this
relationship should be used very
sparingly what does that mean like not a
lot
that is not going into my body this
morning
like
that is gross can you see that yeah make
sure everyone sees it I'm okay to not
try at us I think I think you should I'm
more gearing I'm not trying that are you
going to try that should I get a knife
please of course you can it's braver
than me thank you very much that's these
very Sperry
not good very salty okay a little bit
maybe that's fine it actually doesn't
smell as bad but it tastes like a
fashion check shop
oh no I'm sorry that's
no do you want to try the Bali melu
relish yes please
this is not what is it it's
Tomatoes vinegar sugar onions yeah a Big
Blob on there
it's very popular in Island it is yeah
all right do you want to try a little
bit of this
all right sure I'll you take the small
but I'll take this but
it tastes like strawberry jam I feel
like that has to win because that just
looks like it's horrible dog fecal yeah
feces species yeah yeah when I'm ready
okay I'm gonna count them already yeah
ready three two one
oh yeah look at your eyes yes
okay have you ever had a club rock candy
no okay this is I'm really glad you
chose not Club orange or Club lemon you
chose the Best of Both Worlds yeah yeah
so this is a mixture of lemon and orange
oh okay go first right and I'll go for
the arm
[Music]
Brewing on the budget again that's fine
oh
you want me to open it
there we go
faulty
all right now right
that is the best it is isn't it Irish
yeah
it's delicious yeah yeah do you want to
try the iron Brewers is this just the
winner
not still the winner though yeah
Island one yes
yes
I'm incredibly happy about that
we're gonna have to fight for the end
yeah
I'm not gonna do that
when the cameras turn off we will fight
to the death yeah
thank you
oh
you are wearing identical outfits here
yeah was that planned no no this is not
the first time that we've when was the
other time every every time we wear
something we're always matching yeah I
don't know why that happens but because
we've been with each other for so long
now our minds think the same exactly
that's it yeah that's what I said yeah
toxic waste
what is this all right one two three
oh
oh my God whoa